Je trouve que je suis Jackson à tout moment du jour ou de la nuit, des
drones sont dans le ciel à propos de n'importe
quel endroit abandonné où il y avait la guerre avec ce jour-là,
bien tuer la guerre est maintenant un jeu de
tir à la première personne, la
moitié d'entre vous ont été recrutés parce que vous
êtes un groupe de joueurs
.  quatre alors qu'est-ce que vous enregistrez six
tournées 200 combats pleinement valorisés est-ce si
grave que vous rendiez toujours les gens plus sûrs
carabine droite quand vous êtes prêt c'est comme ça à
bord négatif
Je me sens comme un lâche tous les jours
[Musique]
Je suis un pilote de
combat
[Musique  ]
ils y habitent
[Musique]
toi